je suis même doublement nostalgique et
réactionnaire
[Musique]
j'ai vécu exactement dans des quartiers
qu'ils ont et où la population a été
complètement renouvelé
chez ma mère c'était je dirais même le
sacré au dessus du sacré c'était l'école
quand j'étais au deuxième elle me
traitait de poulidor il me elle me
battait froid pendant quelques jours
[Musique]
et ça monte à une forme d'intelligence
différentes de celles des hommes je suis
désolé de le dire est que les grands
génies son homme je sais que ça ne se
dit pas ça aussi c'est pas fait éliminer
en correct mais c'est la vérité
[Musique]
dit l'homme est un prédateur sexuel un
conquérant mais c'est une incitation au
viol ça non au viol non pas du tout je
continue à penser qu'il y à de la
violence dans le rapport sexuel entre
mes fans il faut qu'il soit un prédateur
sexuel civilisé
[Musique]
je déteste le rap et le rap français
comme le rap américain je trouve ça sans
intérêt donc je vais pas
vanter la qualité de votre musique je
trouve les lélés donc les mélodies
assez pauvre je trouve comme les rives
d'ailleurs pas bref je n'aime rien
[Musique]
les bandes de tchétchènes de rendre deux
kosovars de maghrébins d'africains qui
dévalisent violentes ou des pouilles
[Musique]
moi qui suis napoléonien victor hugo le
général de gaulle disait jacques brel
c'est à sauver les juifs mais répondez
moi oui je vous il a sauvé des juifs
français oui
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié et d'estimé pour
le talent de ces mots pour son courage
parce qu'ils affrontent en effet la
système le est le prêt-à-penser la
pensée unique et il le fait dans des
termes quelquefois très viril il n'a pas
du tout l'intention d'être un acteur
politique
[Musique]
je suis le candidat de l'alliance entre
les classes populaires et la bourgeoisie
patriote je crois que tout est devenu
possible c'est
regarder comment les gens au début
prenez la candidature de donald trump je
refuse à dire que quelque chose est
impossible parce qu'on est
systématiquement démenties par la
réalité qui a beaucoup plus
d'imagination prix